Hi, Dr. Kevin Connors here for your members minute of the day.
Today we're going to talk about cancer in the immune response.
So everybody thinks that, well, cancer, we want to feed the immune system
and that's going to what's killed the cancer.
And they're really right on that, Ms. Pence.
I'll remember, if we ever heard any lecture at all on the immune system,
you have a TH1 side and a TH2 side.
So there's many diseases that tend to be TH1 dominant disorders.
It's not across the board, so don't give you wrong there.
But TH1 dominant disorders tend to be more inflammatory,
more symptomatic picture.
So like chronic Lyme disease, I've said it's typically a TH1 dominant disorder.
So chronic Lyme disease that's TH2 dominant disorder
is the one who can be cured pretty regularly by using an herbal approach.
So an herbal approach has been tried numerous times
with different chronicles, different ways,
and the person's still sick.
Pretty good chance they're TH1 dominant.
In fact, I could bet on it.
So cancer and heart disease tend to be more of a TH2 dominant disorder.
They're chronic, the person's had them a long time before they're diagnosed.
You've known people that, boy, they run five miles a day,
they've been healthy, it's an ox, they've never been in the doctor's office
and they dropped out of a heart attack.
Or they have a massive stroke or something like that.
They had a TH2 dominant reaction going on in the vascular tissue in that example,
in the cardium of the heart.
So when we're talking about cancer,
cancer tends to be a TH2 dominant disorder as well.
At least at the side of the cancer, it's TH2 dominant.
But in fact, we said that the four things that have to take place
for a person to get cancer, the three main things that have to take place,
is they have to have a broken apoptotic cycle.
So apoptosis is the process of normal cell death.
We'll talk about that in a different, never admitted.
The second thing is that they have to have a broken replication cycle.
So the cell replicates every period of time,
like a liver cell every six weeks that replicates a new cell.
So the cancer cells replicating very quickly.
So instead of once every six weeks, it's replicating six times a day.
That's a fast growing cancer.
The third thing that we want to talk about today,
is that they have to have a decreased immune response at some point in time.
Because even if I have a broken apoptotic cycle,
the cell's not dying that should die,
it goes into rapid replication.
That is by definition cancer.
I have a cell that's not dying that's in a rapidly replicating state.
That's cancer.
Still, even though we all have that going on in our body,
this immune system is what keeps it at bay.
So if I buy a liver cell, one of the cells doesn't go through apoptosis,
goes into rapid replication.
Still, I shouldn't have a diagnosis of cancer if I have a healthy immune system.
Because my immune system should recognize that as a pathogen,
as an antigen, as something that's not supposed to be there,
and go, oh my gosh, what's that?
Look at that blob of cells growing like this.
Let's kill it.
That's what the immune system does, and it doesn't well.
So your immune system, if it's healthy,
should recognize that thing as an antigen should kill it.
Believe me, this is what goes on in our body all the time.
So when it said that everybody has cancer in them,
that's what we're talking about.
Everybody does have cancer in them.
There's some cell light that's in a rapid replication cell light,
but your immune system is healthy enough to destroy it.
So what's the side of the immune system that destroys it?
This side, your TH1 side.
So if I go through a real stressful time of my life,
or I have a chemical toxicity, or I have the list goes on and on.
And this is suppressed for some reason, this is suppressed.
And I'm in a TH2 dominant situation.
It doesn't even have to be necessarily an autoimmune situation at this time.
But if I'm TH2 dominant for a period of time,
and this is going on, well, this is unable to kill it.
So if this is a immune system, isn't able to kill it,
this is where cancer can set in.
And even if the stress goes away, and I start living healthy,
and life gets all in order again, the cancer can be too big now
for your immune system to be able to kill it.
For all sorts of reasons.
We'll talk about that later.
That help, as you remember, made it for today.